hello everyone
welcome to rational science live from
frankfurt germany
here i am with my son hans hey guys
and we're going to be doing a little
review of last month
of this month so we're still in the
month of february
and then from there i'm going to move on
to answer some of the questions that
people made throughout the week since
last time
and the last part we're going to open
the floor for questions
and and and comments i guess uh
my son is going to read them out and
i'll do my best to answer them if i
can't answer them today i'll tell you
you got to take a rain check you know
mainly
the check's in the mail okay
okay so let's get started here i'm going
to do with a start with a summary
here it is and uh what we covered this
month or where we started with with
creation and chronology
chronology of what a matter of how
matter came to be
and we started with the question why is
there something
rather than nothing okay question that a
lot of people
typically ask in so-called physics
so-called science what's our answer well
here's a quick
reply to that okay it's uh it's an
irrational question
that's what it is okay it's an
irrational question because
uh the person is framing questions of
philosophy
reasons and purpose why someone does
something
in the context of physics in the context
of mechanisms
and causes that's the problem the person
who
says why is there something rather than
nothing
is uh summarily uh introducing god into
the picture saying there's an
intelligence out there that had a reason
for creating something rather than
nothing okay
that's in general the issue now uh
physics tries to concentrate on
mechanisms and for this you know these
people
usually could try to come up with some
kind of mechanism that would produce
something from nothing
and all i can tell those people is good
luck uh
here's uh the as you can see point
number two there god versus the p
instantan
well uh this is what the christianity
uh i guess the primary religion the west
and uh science essentially proposed
today we have
what we'll call religion there's this
god this being that's been there
forever i guess and he created the
universe that's it
doesn't get any better now we get that
from the bible
and then in the case of science
so-called science
we have the p instantan and uh
so what is this p instead on how to
explain something from nothing
on the traditional a big bang theory you
have time
rolling at the edge of this cone that is
expanding
okay from uh ground zero from the point
where
no no it's it's just that it was uh it's
at some point in time something
began there was an explosion and from
that
point on what we see here in this cone
is that
time flows along the edge of the cone
that's what they changed and they
created the p instanton
and what they did here is they rolled
around space and time
into a circle and a circle has no
beginning and no
end therefore space and time has no
beginning and no end that's that's the
mathematical version of how something
comes into
nothing you just put a circle there and
you say there's no beginning to the
circle no beginning to
no end to the circle and you say that
space and time are like a circle that
forms the bottom
of the p instanton uh which nobody knows
where it came they say it's an
irrational question to ask
even where that could have come from
what is the ps that's on
it's the the one that gave it's the
particle that gave rise to the universe
they didn't have a better name than that
uh no it's the instanton and then they
say it looks like a p so they call it
the p instanton okay
and yeah i discussed that in previous
lectures i assume they don't say where
it came from
no they say it's an irrational question
unscientific question
uh it's unscientific to ask where god
came from
yeah yeah essentially uh it's an
irrational question
because they cannot test it scientific
you cannot run an experiment to prove
how it came into
being there's there's a similarity
between them calling that an irrational
question
you calling why is there nothing instead
of
something an irrational question what's
the difference between those two
well the let's get back in here for a
second just so
yeah uh it's a philosophical question if
you're
if you're in other words phrased in the
context
of physics by saying uh
why is there something rather than
nothing like why did someone create
something rather than nothing in other
that's where it's irrational
otherwise you cannot explain something
from nothing no matter what you do you
cannot explain the mechanism that's why
they say it's unscientific because they
can't answer that question never will
and to say that mathematics can answer
that by saying that
space and time supposedly mathematical
objects or things or whatever are
wrapped around in a circle and there's
no beginning
and no end to a circle that that's how
nothing came into being from something
came into being from nothing
it's a it's a it's a word wizardry
that's what it amounts to and how do you
get around this problem very easily very
easy
the universe came from nothing it's
always been there and it always will be
there there is no
right right so that's the answer anyways
there's another version
and here let me get uh that back in here
okay there's another version and it
doesn't explain the origin of the
universe but it's
called the uh multiverse there's all
these uh
universes out there and one one of those
is ours
marbles yeah cat's eyes because those
are those are the
uh cosmic background radiations that
they get
and they map them and so you know you
can think of them as many
cosmic background radiations one over
here the other one over there
what separated some we don't know
because the little ball there
includes space so the black stuff is not
space
it's the black stuff which they cannot
identify to clarify this isn't a picture
that they took
no no no obviously there are many
pictures yeah there's many
versions of the of the multiverse but
the point here is that
uh these marbles that you see in there
each one of those
includes space it's space space-time
matter
the whole works and so the question is
what's the black stuff that separates
one universe from another
you can't say space because that's what
is included in each marble
obviously it's spacer it's extra space
yeah yeah it's uh
the fourth dimension that could be
thought
yeah i don't know they have to figure
that out
okay so uh moving on here let me uh put
this back here
um that was the multiverse then you have
uh
the origin and chronology of particles
how do they come into being
well here's their version of the
chronology okay
and it starts with a big bang it goes to
the planck
phase then moves on to
the inflationary period the electro weak
all these are sub atomic particles that
were created at different points in time
until they get to this era here the
atomic
period galactic where the galaxies were
formed and then the stars
the stellar okay so that's in general
their version
uh mathematical physics version of how
matter progressed through the ages and
the funny part about this is that
radiation era that you see there that
was in terms of
seconds and at most a minute and what
comes after starts
at thousands of years millions of years
and billions of years so here in the
matter area
era we're in the billions of years now
okay
so they jump from seconds to billions
okay and that that was a little
different than what the
christians or religious folk
proposed through the bible that uh in
seven days god created
all of what exists it took longer yeah
god was kind of slow yeah and i don't
know why he rested because he's all
powerful why would he have to rest but
yeah he
he took one day for each of these things
okay so there's a difference in timing
from the scientific so-called scientific
version and a religion
i love that you compare those two
they're on the same level
okay then we get it the problem here is
that we get later on into the
quasis and uh pseudos and i call them
the quasis because they're really crazy
okay so what are these well um we
covered a little bit of that
and it's got to do with this we look at
the definition of the
quasis and pseudos and what are they
they are quasi particles
what are they their collective
excitations
of what uh emergent phenomena in other
words what you have like you see on the
bottom right there you see a whole bunch
of uh
atoms molecules whatever unit you want
to use
and they move as a whole they
move as a collection and they're going
to call the collective
movement a particle they're going to say
that's a pseudo particle that you're
staring at down there
okay what's moving well what's moving is
maybe the atom
the yeah the atoms within a molecule for
example
okay in that case you have a crystal
lettuce you have the atom moving around
a little bit
and the collective movement of this the
whole thing okay
they call that a part they give it a
name they call it well it's a pseudo
it's not a particle it's a pseudo
particle or a quasi particle something
like
a concept trying to become an object
and uh and here you see one of those the
the one i well the first one that i
covered was this the p
on there okay and then you get this
other one which is the
phone on we covered it the other day
this is a collective movement
okay and these are different phonons
that you will see here okay
i don't like the term collective
movement that sounds like someone trying
to get away with murder yeah and that's
what it is
uh what what you see is collective
movement each one of these is a
different kind of
phonon because they have different kinds
of vibrations
they require different equations to
map these or to represent these and so
each one of these is a different phonon
they say oh that's phonon number one
that's phone number number two and so on
the different sets of yeah there's
different sets of vibrations
okay so each one of these is a different
phone okay so the same group
of could be particles no they would make
different particles that's one issue and
the other one is that you
what the reason they call them phonons
is they say
that at the subatomic level these are
producing
sound so the phonon is a particle of
sound a pseudo-particle of sound
okay each one of these vibrations
produces some kind of sound
that they are able to represent with an
equation
that's how they ended up with these
being
uh you know particles or whatever
pronouns for
uh to listen they say you can't hear if
you can if you don't have
what do you use quasi particles for
again it's it's just uh
what they're doing is representing um
with equations these things
so that they can talk about them and
they say oh we study phonons
what kind of fun we study the a kind or
the b kind the other guy
studies the x or y z kind you know so in
order
to publish their papers what they do is
they use these terms which they've
created
and they say well this one's a pseudo
particle it's not really a particle like
the little ball it's a collective
excitation we're going to
group that together and they say well we
studied phonon which one well we did
this
experiment and we found this vibration
moving from a to b
and we're going to call that phonon a
and that's the one that moved over
that's the one we're talking about
these other guys they did something
another experiment they talk about the
phone on z
you know the beauty about that is if
they if they're moving on to collective
uh motion and calling collective motions
new pseudo parts particles that they can
get rewards for
then they don't have to find new
materials they just take the ones that
there
are and make different sounds out of
them oh this new
song here this is a phone on this new
song here this is a blue one
yeah but that's the thing they can they
can invent as many as they want now
because now it's like it's almost like
notes in a in a music piece yeah
essentially
they can invent as many as they create
job security for a lot of people because
all they do is they say well i'm going
to study phonons and what kind of
phoneme well i study these vibrations
that go up and down the other guy
says well i study the ones that go
horizontal back and forth
and so as long as you can put that in
that context and say well i'm going to
study the
horizontal the other guy the vertical
phonons well they have different
specialties
i'm a specialist in horizontal photons
and so they develop equations to map
or to represent those motions and they
publish papers on that and it goes on
and on and on
okay let's uh continue here with the
final part uh the last uh
one uh again is the hole that i covered
the other day and here it is
these are the charge carriers okay
and uh what you're seeing there is no
longer an electron a negative electron
going from
negative to positive pole you see the
opposite you see an
uh an absence of an electron
known as a hole and it's going to the
negative
terminal to the cathode okay and so they
have the flowing of
holes and you say well
what does that mean what can this
possibly mean and and this is how they
do it because they need to explain uh
things like depletion
layers uh in semiconductors and in order
to explain those the physical
interpretation is that
you have holes going one way and
electron positive holes by the way
because these are positive ones and that
means yeah and then the
negative electrons go the other way so
they do have flow of electron current
which is positive and current which is
holes
and this is more or less what it looks
like i saw this in the uh
this is where you get it this is in um
bugs bunny cartoon okay
you see the whole movie okay so this
this is what we have uh this is what
science has become
okay okay so that's where we ended in
general that's a summary
okay what we had you didn't get a lot
done in february did you
well no because it was all pseudo
particles and creation of uh
particles that we don't know how they
were created because again they don't
want
to answer what happened in frame number
one they started frame number two which
is the big bang
and you say okay but what happened in
frame number one and right
the one in the movie right before that
and they said that's an irrational
question
but it's an unscientific question
because we cannot possibly know how time
started
and then you still have some
mathematicians out there like hawking
and turok and they go out there and they
say well
we know oh how do you know yeah we what
we did we wrapped around space around
time we made them into a circle and
there's no beginning and an end to a
circle so that's what does that even
mean that doesn't mean anything
going up to religious people not that
i'm defending or anything but it's just
weird that they would be like oh
where did god come from well you got the
same problem
yeah yeah essentially one one half of
the world laughs at the other half
that's all we have yeah yeah it's two
hands laughing at each other
in fact i think a lot of creationists
also kind of get off on it because they
say oh well you're just doing god with
extra steps
yeah essentially that's what it is they
are doing god with extra steps but see
they have the nerve to laugh
because most of these people are
atheists and so they they don't believe
that there's a god out there but their
their explanations are just as fantastic
or even more fantastic because i can
imagine
god and the guy says look god's eternal
you got to take that as a given okay
i'll accept that but then i can imagine
god with a magic wand creating whatever
he wants
even though i can't imagine the
mechanism of how from nothing
he creates something but i can
understand god
doing magic and creating all this stuff
that part we can all visualize what we
cannot visualize
is something by itself arising from
absolutely nothing
and when you ask the guy well how did
that happen he said that's an irrational
question
the bug stops there at least god was
there you can push the blame off to god
but
something coming from nothing is like
okay dude does that just happen
yeah okay so let's move on to the
questions real quick wouldn't that mean
that at any moment at any given moment
another big bang can
come up uh yeah that's the multiverse
the version
uh here where you have uh where was it
the multiverse here
that's this version is that how they
explain that yeah they say that all
these big bangs
come pop into existence trillions of
years whatever then they go out of
existence then they pop
another universe pops up over there and
another one over in the other side
and ours is one of those that's that's
that's the explanation they give you
but they don't have the people who
propose the multiverse they're not into
creationism in a sense of saying that
they can tell you
what is in frame number one they cannot
tell you what the mechanism is for one
of these universe to pop into existence
now don't put it be beyond them that
they might do it like
uh today we explain for example the
creation of solar systems
which is there's an explosion of
a supernova which is a big star
essentially it explodes and it shoots
all this matter out there that somehow
coalesces begins running around itself
with gases and so on and that eventually
condenses into a solar system if that's
just a pattern
yeah one place to another right yeah and
and that's what i'm saying here the same
thing
here you have a universe let's assume
right and maybe there's an explosion or
maybe it drifts apart
and whatever matter is in there forms
another universe over there
maybe don't put it beyond that they're
going to come up with something like
that
from the multiverse idea they say well
it's all these multiverses you know they
just
explode or they drift out of existence
and the matter that came out of
existence there
forms one universe over here another law
of forms over there
so that might be the next uh great uh
theory of uh relativity okay
okay let's get on with a question so we
move on here
uh issues one fellow put this issue here
says nowhere does quantum mechanics
um say that particle actually travels
all possible paths nowhere if any
so-called physicist says
that then they don't understand quantum
mechanics whoa
okay the fact that this canard is uh
repeated by uh clueless dissidents
such as yourself okay is a source of
amusement to the physics community
you're dumb your dumbest followers
that's you uh won't know any better when
you feed them this tripe
but real physicists get a chuckle out of
your inane
uh uniform rants okay so this is what uh
what these guys are saying what this
fellow is saying okay let's find out
what the answer to that is
he says that there is essentially okay
that there is no such
notion in quantum mechanics that a
particle actually travels from a to b
through all possible paths and uh
you know this has to do with a path
integral that richard feynman came up
with
okay and what he's saying okay so that
we put in the right context
he's saying that a particle quantum
particle you know doesn't go just from a
to b
like a classical corpuscle okay the
quantum particle
goes all around the universe in
different directions
and and then arrives at point b so not
only does it go straight but it takes
different paths to get to b and it also
goes
all around the universe to get the b and
it's not that it can
it's that it does all possible paths
do actually happen okay so let's get
that straight that's what we're saying
so he's saying no that's not true
that's idiocy uh i agree there it's
idiocy okay
but let's find out if it's true now
let's let's get some medividens here
okay here's a
first piece of evidence i can get it up
there
okay here's uh here's the first guy that
says uh
and this is a lady she's a retired
physicist okay she's got all those
degrees there
and she says it is path integral theory
finding speaks
of a particle that travels from a time
space point
right to another time space point this
particle travels on whatever possible
trajectory between these two points
no matter how irregular is the
trajectory the trajectories are
continuous
and the set visits in fact between t1
and t2
all the points in the in the 3d space
what did you say so far so good though
the abnormal fact in this story is that
the particle
does not travel one trajectory after
that another trajectory and so on but
travels
all these trajectories in parallel
that means that between t1 and t2 the
particle goes
simultaneously along all
the trajectories so that at any given
point t
uh time t between t1 and t2 the particle
is simultaneously
in many points in the space
uh i didn't say that this lady says that
you say well who is she
i mean she she got it wrong she's one of
those maybe dissidents who get it wrong
okay
so let's find out uh okay she doesn't
know anything
let's go with someone a little more
important someone that everybody knows
here's a girl brian green
okay i guess a lot of people know him
he's been on tv
you know he's a guy who's uh
uh made some documentaries and so on he
says the following
okay these are his words not mine okay
he comes out of the elegant universe
uh one of the documentaries he made on
so-called physics
mathematical physics feinman took this
step one step further in postulating
that
in traveling from the source to a given
point on the screen
each individual electron actually
traverses every possible trajectory
simultaneously
did i put words in his mouth or anything
it goes in a nice orderly way listen to
this
through the left slit it can
simultaneously goes
in a nice orderly way through the right
slit it heads towards the left slip but
suddenly
changes course and heads through the
right he's talking about the slit
experiment okay
it meanders back and forth finally
passing through the left slit
it goes on a long journey to the
andromeda galaxy before turning back
and passing through the left slit on its
way to the screen and on
and on it goes the electron according to
feynman
simultaneously sniffs out every possible
path
connecting its starting location with
its final destination
and you add up the probabilities of all
conceivable paths
uh did i misread something is there
something i'm not understanding perhaps
well let's find out uh here's a green on
twitter this is just a
month ago in january he wrote this okay
that's his account you can see uh
he puts an equation there and he says
the following here's one
shocking thing about quantum mechanics
these are his words
twitter one month ago as a particle
travels
it explores every possible path and what
we
observe is a melding of them all
did i misunderstand something okay you
might say well that's brian green
what does he know he's just a movie star
okay let's let's
go through all of them i know just one
more here okay let's get stephen hawking
you heard of stephen hawking hopefully
he's dead he doesn't count yeah but he
he left his will here's his will okay
here's stephen hawking in a brief
history of time
probably the best seller in so-called
physics or mathematical physics for the
public okay he says
a nice way of visualizing the wave
particle duality is the so-called sum
over histories introduced by the
american
uh mathematician mathematician richard
feynman
okay in this approach the particle is
not supposed to have a single history or
path
in space time as it would incl in a
classical
non-quantum theory instead it is
supposed to go from a to b
by what by every possible path
okay with each path there is an
associated uh
couple of numbers etcetera etcetera okay
whatever he's telling you in your face
the particle goes through every path
i didn't invent that i'm just repeating
what these people say okay
who's this guy yeah who is stephen
hawking anyways right he's just
uh what the lucasian professor at uh
cambridge and just in case um in
in a second book that he wrote after
this one
because this was uh like 2010 uh the
second book here
the brand design he says the following
okay
again writing on this subject says
according to the quantum model however
the particle is said to have no definite
position during the time it is between
the starting point
and the endpoint rather than following a
single definite path
particles take every path and they take
them all
simultaneously his uh italics
is there something i'm not understanding
perhaps okay
you gotta read between the lines they
don't mean it yeah and
just in case here we have let's let's
get mr feinman to testify for himself
he's dead too but he left
his testimony here it is okay says
it is it true that the particles he says
this in lecture number 19
uh his finding lectures and it's titled
the principle of least action
where he actually explains you know the
the path integral and he gave these
between 61 and 64. he says
is it true that the particle doesn't
just take
the right path but that it looks at all
the other possible trajectories
the miracle of it all is of course that
it does just that that is his words they
take all possible paths
he says that's what the laws of quantum
mechanics say
okay so these are the laws of quantum
mechanics it's not like i'm inventing
anything here
okay it isn't that a particle takes the
path
of least action but that it smells all
the past in the neighborhood
and chooses the one that has the least
action
so we have particles choosing you know
they have this intelligence okay
well you can read the rest of it there
later but that's the point the point is
that
yes i know it sounds ridiculous it
sounds irrational it sounds
uncommonsensical and nonsensical
yeah and what all these people are
telling you is
yes from a to b quantum not not
classical mechanics but quantum
mechanics
proposes that a particle takes all
imaginable paths
and then it's not that it can it's that
it
does indeed take all these paths because
the particle is everywhere at once
according to
quantum mechanics where did they get
that they got that from the uncertainty
principle heisenberg's
uh principle of indeterminacy and it
says that a particle essentially behaves
like a wave suddenly when you're not
looking
you don't have to look you don't have to
peek because that's cheating
okay and so what he says if you're not
looking the particles everywhere
and only it condenses to a a
point when you look and touch and
measure it
then it suddenly there's the wave
function collapse
it knows it's what it's being watched
yeah yeah it doesn't like it doesn't
like to be what maybe
it's nude and covers itself real quick
and then it you know goes again
as a wave so yeah that's what quantum
mechanics is saying
so if you think that's rational well
that's up to you to determine
uh personally uh i can give you my
opinion
i think it's nonsense okay but that's
the only explanation they have because
they have this
uncertainty principle and they have the
principle complementary that
uh a particle is a wave and wave is a
particle and they have the
um what is it the uh
exclusion principle they have all these
principles which form the foundations of
quantum mechanics
now you're going to challenge that after
100 years of quantum
come on okay another fellow
asked a different kind of question here
and he said
is it a question or is he just gonna
[ __ ] on you but yeah
i feel like most of these hurt ninety
percent just oh we bring these guys just
uh
so we learn we learn what the arguments
are okay
says what a bunch of gobbly [ __ ] this
talk
a field is a bunch of numbers
cannot exert forces because that's what
i'm saying you know i'm saying you know
a field cannot
exert forces and it is a bunch of
numbers
and this guy's questioning that he said
what the hell are you talking about
everyone knows and testifies that the
electric field whatever the name you do
for this
exerts a force exerts force on any type
of matter
independent of its type so the magnetic
field
is also a concept yeah
uh the force you feel gushing and
pushing and
pulling your hands is also fantasy uh
yeah uh because force is not a physical
object so
that's why i think you need to review
your basic philosophy
oh laughing out loud okay let's find out
what philosophy word
let's find out what the uh answer to
that is
okay here we have it and uh it goes
something like this uh
we look up the word field so we know
what we're talking about and
this is out of uh the wikipedia it says
a quantity what is a field equality
we're already off to the wrong side so i
was saying that he says what is a bunch
of numbers yeah that's what it is
uh field equality represented by a
number
that has a value for each point in space
and time
a graph essentially yeah it's a bunch of
numbers like you see on the bottom left
there but isn't that essentially used as
a graph
fields uh what do you mean uh aren't all
fields essentially used as a graph
like they they take two uh they use x
and x's and y's to kind of say this is
this many
units away from that yeah yeah yeah
essentially that is but what the
the field is the composite of all of
them it's not just
one uh point a field is but it says
it has a value for each point in space
and time in other words
the field is the whole works it's not
just one value
that's only a component of the field the
field is the whole thing in other words
if you have a gravitational field
you look at the how strong it is
near the center of of gravity
so you have the earth let's assume it's
perfectly around as per
let's assume the center of gravity is uh
the center of the earth okay
that gravitational field extends beyond
the
borders of the object of the object
which is
uh the earth and what are we talking
about well we're talking about
values of gravitational potential or
strength the farther away you get from
the earth
same with uh electric field same with
gravity uh magnetic field
but that's essentially used to map yeah
exactly
that's what it's not actually uh
the map isn't the territory yeah but the
point here is the word field refers to
that map
to to the volume of numbers of
units of quantities of amounts that
surround an
object so they're referring to the
amounts because it's a mathematical
concept we have to understand that
and uh but here's the problem here's the
little trick this is how it's done
and this also out of the same source so
wikipedia says a field
occupies space what do you mean occupy
how do
how does a quantity a number a value
how does that occupy space suddenly they
they morphed
the quantity number value amount uh
whatever you want to call it they turned
it into a physical
object like you see on the bottom they
took all those numbers and turned it
into a rock
they're saying length is an object
what they're saying is essentially that
these bunch of numbers suddenly
converted into
something that takes space takes up
space says contains energy
and its presence precludes a classical
true vacuum
meaning you don't have vacuum there
anymore now you have something
that's interrupting the vacuum and he he
said
listen to this next statement says this
has led physicists
physicists to consider electromagnetic
fields to be
a physical entity so something we
invented to map
an area is now an object and
and just in case the word entity you
look it up something that has
real existence a thing what are the
synonyms
body material matter organism substance
thing
something so yeah they converted this
number
they converted into a thing and this is
where the danger comes in that's uh
that's a
you know a quick magic trick that they
did right there they said we're gonna
convert this into a thing because we
need to relate
what we're talking about to physics
because otherwise it would be just pure
mathematics nobody would
care but they say no no no yeah listen
to us you know these numbers here that
are around there
they occupy space they have to translate
it into something
oh yeah it's some form of pseudo physics
tangible seeable yeah just just that it
has some bearing on reality if it's just
all numbers that is
so good so here's a field for you if you
want to see a field here it is okay
that's a field and it's a magnetic field
and you see the magnet that's a physical
object
okay but now we're going to remove the
magnet
and what are we going to leave we're
going to leave the field only is there
such a thing as a standalone
field i mean is that an object well to
clarify i think the guy
the original post that you the original
question there i think
that person as well as many others
confused the effects
right around a so-called field with the
field like as if it's
they're confusing the numbers of amounts
with the effects that we see
but that's what that's why we have to
define these terms we have to know what
the word field means or refers to you
can't just say
well we use a field every day like you
know here's a field we have two magnets
okay those two black ones there and you
have a magnetic
field somewhere something is in there
yeah something and so they call that
something that takes up space or that
whatever
they define it as a bunch of numbers but
then they say now they they're going to
treat it as
as a physical thing they say there's a
field in there a magnetic field
that's called it but you you made a jump
from mathematics into physics
without any justification you turn this
definition which is
a whole bunch of numbers and you turn
that into a physical object you say well
there's an object there they jump
between the two as if there were no
barriers
right right this is where the danger
comes in and again that's why i remove
the magnet and say
is there a standalone field is there a
physical object there
that just stands alone and of course a
lot of people at least would say no
there's no such monster you need you
can't bring the field into the
conference room
you need to bring the magnets okay
otherwise the field
uh stays behind okay
and uh so here's um here's what a field
really is
and here you have all different kinds of
fields uh you have magnetic you have
gravitational etc electric and here it
is
here's what they are that's creepy uh
what are these these are
all uh vectors that's what they are
because a field is modeled with vectors
what are vectors they're number lines
they have magnitude and direction and
what you see
that's what you're seeing okay what
they've done is take these vectors and
put them in motion
these are mathematical concepts which
are
numbers that have direction right if you
can imagine that
and they define it as such but then they
put them into motion they they represent
them with a little arrow
indian arrow and they start moving them
around and so you say well i understand
what that is
there's uh this field moving no no
there's no field moving what you're
staring at is a bunch of
mathematical vectors number lines
magnitude and direction that suddenly
they are represented by arrows and they
start moving them around you say well
yeah that occupies space obviously what
you're staring at is
numbers you're saying there's a three
pointing north and they're moving the
three pointing
exactly what does that even mean it has
no meaning but see they had to
have a physical interpretation to their
mathematical
description or equations or
you know so what their numbers their
definitions so so they have all these
numbers
vectors magnitude and direction they
represent it with an
arrow and you say okay i know what an
arrow is that's what the engine killed
the
soldier with right yeah and so they put
a little arrow there and they say okay
that's a physical object
then they put many of these arrows
because what is a field a field is a
bunch of numbers
from a given point and here we have a
bunch of arrows a bunch of number lines
from a point represented by an arrow and
then they put them into motion which is
very scary because now
now the numbers the number lines are
moving that's very scary stuff uh
the the arrow the magnitude has
magnitude because they're moving
they're moving an arrow it's already a
number with direction but then if you
move it this way that means it has
its own yeah they change the direction
of the
arrow because uh what happens is for any
given point they
they show how it moves okay and they
represent that motion what is called a
translation or a transformation in in
mathematics
what they do is they start moving these
arrows these number lines around very
scary stuff
but when you have a whole bunch of them
because again a field is a whole bunch
of these numbers
well then you have all this motion you
say wait i understand that yeah i see
why it occupies space
and you're staring at number lines being
represented by arrows because they had
to put some
physical thing there to represent their
equations their numbers their
definitions this is where the danger is
when you turn
that mathematics into physics with no
justification no
no way to uh you know to back that up
with
okay and uh so under the rope model we
like to always point that out
here it is uh are we talking about a
physical entity representing a magnetic
field
yes here it is okay if i can put it up
there there it is
oh we're doing actual physics yeah yeah
and so now you see there are threads
under the rope model
what we have are threads and those
threads those
moving threads represent or not
represent they're
actually the the field you don't have to
use the word refrigerant yeah here you
don't need to replace reproduce imagine
it like that no
it is yeah it is what you have here is
that those
uh the so-called field is mediated by
threads that are moving around
and i don't have it here today but uh in
general
i've shown that a magnetic field
if you if you put a magnet under water
it collects
one iron filing at a time because
there's something
sweeping you know the so-called field
static field
there's no such monster field is made of
something that is in motion
or like james maxwell said there's
matter
in motion it's not instant
it right it's not insane you you
something under the water because you
can see it in slow motion essentially
when it when the magnets under water
you can see the magnetic field whatever
that is
pulling one iron filing at a time what
do you have
under the rope model you have one the
threads moving around
and they're picking up these uh iron
filings and putting them against the
magnet itself
so we do have a physical object
representing the field or
or mediating simulating the field they
don't what they have is number lines
which they arbitrarily put an arrow
there what's an arrow it's a
vector and then they start moving the
vectors
because they're not interested in what
really is in that invisible
intangible region what they want to do
is just map it
with number nine they just gave the
motions and forces names but they didn't
say
what what first them on right does that
and so you cannot visualize their
mechanism because they're representing
them with numbers
and they cheat and they say well that's
really an arrow it's not an error you're
staring at a number line
magnitude and direction and as long as
you keep that in mind don't lose sight
of that you'll see that you
will have no physical interpretation for
what a magnet is or how it works or what
a field is
they define it again as a concept after
cons a bunch of numbers and then they
turn it into a rock
okay another issue that was raised and
several people
had questions on this so i'm just going
to put one of them okay and
we're going to address the main one the
first fellow who put this in there okay
it's got to do with the thread
okay paul says the thread doesn't exist
according to your definition of the term
exists
which you see at the bottom what is
exist physical presence
in order to define the word exist you
need an object and the object must have
location
okay so if god wants to exist it's not
enough that he's an
object like you know a magician he's got
to have location there's got to be
distance between my chest and his
otherwise god doesn't exist by
definition because we do have a
definition of exist now and that's what
he's referring to he's saying
well if there's a single thread out
there one thread
in the universe right well what is
that in relation to what is this thread
located with respect to if it's a single
thread in the universe that was his
his concern okay that's a good question
one person uh
answered all that he says please explain
okay one guy took the first words out of
my mouth
and he says yes the threat doesn't exist
according to
his my definition of exist what do you
need exp
uh explained and he took that first part
out of my mouth he beat me to it okay
fine but this guy continued and he came
comes back says
no threat he's trying to explain why he
wants an explanation he says
no thread no rope no hypothesis in other
words
if if you cannot say that the threat
exists
then uh then you can your whole theory
goes down the drain because
uh the threat you're talking about you
according to your own definition doesn't
exist that's that's his argument okay
okay that's right now we answer this
very simple okay
let's make it exist he wants it the
thread that exists let's make it exist
okay here it is okay
we're gonna make it exist if i can get
this thing up there they're all at the
bottom
so we're not going to use the instant on
are we okay here it is
okay so now it exists we have two
threads right and
one thread exists with respect to the
other thread
okay they have location they have
distance with respect to each other
there's two of them
okay and remember what this represents
these represent
uh two universes remember the thread uh
really turns into this
okay where you have these two universes
they're all tied together in other words
the thread
turns into atoms which turn into ropes
which turn into atoms and eventually
into stars
galaxies whatever okay and now you're
gonna say well bill you cheated
you cheated because uh you put an extra
thread in there i thought it was a
single thread
yeah so i'm a cheater
i'm on this guy's side okay uh so he
puts
he puts he says the threat doesn't exist
because you have a single thread well i
put another thread what's
wrong with that i mean it's speculation
right
you say well how do you know it exists
well it exists by definition because now
we have two threads
that's why uh remember whether there's a
first thread or a single thread or in
other words the single thread refers to
our universe
and it could be another single oh we got
the multiverse
100 you want 100 threads we'll put 100
threads in there okay
we have space right and we have these
threads
and one thread is located with respect
to another thread with respect to
another thread and so on down the line
so what's wrong with that now we have
the existence of the thread you wanted
existence i gave you existence
but let me tell you what the real
problem is let's get to the bottom of
this okay that that's just a word
wizardry i just gave you okay i'm just
putting another thread there to show you
that yeah it can exist all you have to
do is put another thread now you have
one thread what with respect to another
thread right
and you say you're a cheater bill you
put another thread by
um by proxy there you just
just did it to win the conversation
that's unfair you just wanted to win the
debate and so you said see now it exists
well it does exist
because that's the definition of exist
what's the issue
this is the issue let's get down to the
rock bottom to what the issues are there
are several
issues let me bring this up i'm going to
cover your face
okay here are the issues okay
[Laughter]
uh i didn't call it the
thread the hypothesis i called it the
rope hypothesis
why because the thread is irrelevant
we do absolutely nothing with the
single thread let me repeat that
we do absolutely nothing in physics with
a single thread
unless unless you're talking about
another thread another universe
then we can do something with the thread
talk about the universe as a whole
in other words treat the thread as
a an object that has location with
respect to another object
because they're not bound to each other
in any way so there is distance there's
separation
we're done okay so the only time you're
going to use
the single thread is if there is another
single thread
out there otherwise you have no use for
the single thread we use we have no use
for the single thread in physics
what are the issues in physics well uh
the thread is uh again there's uh
there's
uh not it's not an issue in physics any
more than a parallel universe is an
issue in physics these are speculations
we say well what if there were another
universe well then you get into a
chat by the water cooler and talk about
that
but that doesn't concern us what are we
concerned with we're concerned in
physics with
visible and invisible phenomena the
visible ones we figured them all out a
long time ago
okay we can see the seesaw we can see
the rock going through the window we can
see the pulley
pulling on something we we see these
things all those are done
the ones we have not figured out are the
ones you see there light gravity
magnetism electricity in the atom
those are invisible intangible and
that's where we're having problems
because people
are not used to representing those or
mediating them
or simulating them with physical
objects because we can't see and touch
them and we always thought that an
object is that which you can see and
touch
and we're saying it's that which has
shape and now we have a different uh
notion of what these things are they're
mediated by things that have shape
okay but what is the issue here these
phenomena are mediated by atoms and
ropes
okay and so we get to a little point
that we find out that the thread is the
only object in the universe
because everything else is connected as
you see below and let me give you here
an example
so you can see where i'm going with this
okay
uh you get it up here
then there's one more no
i lost it ah so at the top
where where'd he go
it's not showing up oh you have to click
the i
oh that's what it is okay jesus uh
good thing you saw that okay so we have
the rock
and we have a table but it turns out
that
the only thing the only reason we can
treat the rock different from the table
is that we can't see the ropes so we say
well the rock isn't
a discrete entity and so is the table
but under the rope model if
every atom from the rock is connected to
every atom of the table
well then the rock continues and becomes
the table and the table continues and
becomes the rock
there is no difference between these two
objects the only real object in the
universe
is the single thread right that's
according to the rogue model
everything's connected but are we saying
that we're not going to talk about
rocks we're not going to talk about
tables because everything in the
universe is connected and everything is
mediated by a single thread the
single thread in the universe we're here
trying to do physics
and physics deals with light gravity
etc okay magnetism and so
we're going to talk about objects and
we're going to treat them as
if you know as if they have a border a
surface
we're not going to include the ropes
when we talk about raw
rock or table we have to treat them as
discrete objects
they end where where the visible or
tangible part ends which is
the last atom and then from there the
rope that continues we're not going to
consider that
part of the rock because the rope is
going to go to the table and going to go
to the house and
go to the dog and so on you're saying
for the for the questions we want to
answer
we don't need the thread we don't need
the thread at all the only time we need
the thread
and that's what i'm going to show next
okay this is when we need the thread
okay and it's only locally okay that's
when we talk about the thread
and here's one example okay which i just
showed a minute ago
now we have now we need the thread
because we have to explain
how uh threads attract how magnets
attract
other magnets by way of the thread by
simulating
the field with a thread but now we're
talking about the local
action of the thread we're not talking
about the single thread that underlies
all matter
we have no use for the single thread we
only have use for the
thread locally and here's another
example
okay which are the i think the only two
instances where we used a single thread
okay and it's uh how the uh how the uh
what is it how the uh yeah the electron
shell is built
okay let me get this one out here okay
this time you get
like you get to see you so the the
atom is weaved the surface of the atom
is weaved by countless threads
coming from every rope in the universe
that converges on our atom
and so those are the only time we talk
about the thread so the thread weaves
and constructs
the atom it constructs not only the
proton dnd language is just a bunch of
threads
okay it also constructs the electron
shell that
encapsulates the proton dandelion as we
call it or
you can call it the urchin
anyway you want a star any word will do
find any description
and what that's the only time you talk
about the thread because the thread
locally can be used to explain these
things
but the global thread the one that
underlies all matter we have no use for
it
except when we're talking about another
universe and i just showed
that when we put another universe out
there then the threads exist both of
them
okay so that's the issue the issue is
that people who harp on the word dread
are just
people who lost their religion and
they're trying to they can't win the
game they can't beat them
so they want to tie them or this is a
confirmation of multiverses
no because again that's speculation you
can speculate about that but again that
goes to the water cooler that has really
little to do with actual
physics you're not going to explain
anything in physics like magnetism here
or gravity or anything like that by
talking about the single thread
which is existing with respect to
another thread that could be out there
that's that's for speculation that's
good to talk about
but it it doesn't pertain specifically
to physics
but all physics is is water cooler talk
no no i gotta explain the mechanic i
gotta explain this mechanism that's
still water cooler talk isn't it no no
it's not
what's the difference
no this one i gotta explain the
mechanism and all i'm saying here is
that well there's no mechanisms
no no this is the issue the issue is
that i'm going to explain to you an
objective mechanism
so that you understand it you say this
is what i propose that's happening
between these two magnets
the threats move around this is how they
attract this is how they repel that's it
whether you believe that there are
threads whether you believe in the
theory that's your personal issue
but my my point is that physics is about
explaining a mechanism i explain a
mechanism i'm done that's what i need
the thread for
but when you're talking about something
like the global threat assuming there's
only one in the universe
there's no purpose in talking about uh
the threat it's
i'm not going to use that for anything
and if you say well does it exist
well it exists if we have another
universe out there another thread out
there
and because what are you going to use
that threat for
only in re reference to another threat
into
in the multi-universe otherwise you have
no no
reason to raise the issue of the single
thread existing or not well you would
with itself i guess
yeah but all you're doing is defining
the word exist that's your issue
and if you want to talk about the word
exist i'll make it exist immediately
i'll make another thread where another
thread exists these are single threads
many single threads each one is a
universe
so we're talking about the word exist
not about the thread
and it's very easy to make the thread
exist like it's easy to make god exist
just make another guide
[Laughter]
that's so simple they need the thread to
exist that's the point
we don't unless we're talking about
another threat then we need it do we
need the word exists for the thread
that's what i'm saying if you're going
to talk about the thread talk about the
threat you're going to talk about exist
we make it exist immediately we make
another thread very simple
i do it with my magic wand cheating
that's how i do it
okay uh another issue moving on here
real quick before we go
would that mean the location could
location be
change to things along the thread then
not the thread yeah but basically when
you're talking about a table and a ball
you're talking about two different
chunks
yeah and that's essentially it uh when
we talk about exists we usually talk
about anything made out of atoms
okay so we say the table exists the one
that i'm touching the one that i see
uh even the air that you can't see you
say well exist because i can move my
hand and there's something now i'll call
that air
and it's made out of atoms or at least
it's proposed that it's made out of
atoms any gas for that matter water is
also made out of atoms
so we talk about things that exist as
being made of atoms
in the real world we don't talk about
exist
in terms of energy meaning
the mediator of light okay we don't say
does light exist well light exists yeah
in the sense that i shine it on the wall
and i see something there and
in that sense it exists when you say
well does the energy that supposedly
mediates that what is that well that's a
concept and so
you get into this run around now when we
use the word exist we usually
refer to atoms locally we talk about the
chair we talk about the table we talk
about the dog the house
and and so we talk about things of that
nature and that's
the context of the word exists and what
we're saying is when you're going to use
that word
exist which is you know physics is the
science of existence
then what you have to do is apply it
locally and say well does the table
exist well yes it does
what do you mean by that well all we're
saying is it has locations an object
that has location i think the problem
with definitions usually
arises when we're talking
about definitions without an actual
presentation no one's giving you a
presentation we're just defining words
for the sake of defining words
no one's giving a presentation so you
can't define this
word in a vacuum because it has no use
it has it's not being applied
so you can't really see where it's
falling apart you are
when you're uh saying a theory in other
words
if people say well love exists and they
just say that well yeah you can use that
in poetry
but if you're going to talk about hey
you know god exists i can prove it and
here's my evidence or where now you
walk the line into physics and now you
got to talk rationally now you have to
define the word exist very
specifically because we need to
understand what you're saying but if you
just say you know
the mountain exists and in ordinary
speech or love exists or intelligence
exists or we don't know what you're
talking about it doesn't matter you
don't have to be specific
because it's okay ordinary speech does
not require
very uh rigid definitions okay
rigorous etc if if you're gonna
make a theory if you're gonna talk even
at the water cooler about a theory
whether you know or not you've
cross-lined into physics now you better
be rational
and if you're gonna be rational the
first thing define your terms
especially the words like object and
exist those two need to be defined
because
you're going to talk to me about what's
real out there you're going to say well
you know i saw the ghost
well does the ghost exist well yes i
know it exists because i can touch it
well is that the definition of exist if
you're going to talk
ratio if you're going to talk seriously
right then you better define your terms
otherwise you can say whatever you want
okay because then you can say love
touched me yeah because you you got to
try to
you have to try to understand what the
person is saying if the guy's just going
to use ordinary speech and not define
his terms
well he's just going to be chasing his
tail and you're going to go around in
circles because you don't understand
what he's saying
you have to pinpoint the the problem and
that's definition you got to say what
did you mean by object what did you mean
by exist
and that's where the trouble comes in
because people are not used to defining
these terms
not in a rigorous manner okay
okay let's move on here's another issue
the person says the ether
okay it says
he says ether is the name of the black
stuff
oh it is an object the black stuff okay
but it doesn't exist because it goes to
infinity and therefore has no location
okay again he's using the same
definition we just use object plus
location
it is uh synonymous with space and the
thread
which thread is he talking about he's
talking about the single thread uh
no and let's find out why okay we got a
problem with this
several problems okay so let's clarify
each one of these problems
uh here's the first one
or several at the same time there we go
okay here's the
ether and you can see that when we talk
about the ether we talk about
light because what these people are
saying is that the ether
mediates light it's the vibration of the
ether
that uh that's that's what light is the
vibration of the ether
and so you can't say that the white
stuff is
uh that the black stuff is the ether no
it's the white stuff
or otherwise what is the white stuff
tell me what the white stuff is then
if if the black stuff is the ether
what's the white stuff
and then again uh you know they they
always say that light is the waving of
the ether and what's that a bunch of
particles
that's what the ether has always been
they just say that
that's the sandbox or beehive all these
bees moving around
up and down for some reason in a
coordinated way where they have these
sine waves
and so yeah okay so it's the particles
they're talking about the particles
moving up and down and creating these
waves so yeah the ether is a bunch of
particles that's what it's always been
if you have a different definition you
have to define the word ether and tell
us exactly what you mean by that
and hopefully you cannot define the word
ether because if you do define the word
ether it's not an object
objects we don't define objects we point
to it is concepts that we define
then the black stuff cannot be infinite
because because if it is it's not an
object we have no objects that are
infinite so again
if the spell says that it goes to
infinity but it's an object no
no way black still cannot go to infinity
if it
because otherwise if it's infinite it
defeats the definition of
object which is finite and if it's
finite you got to tell me what's out on
the outside of it
limiting the black stuff what's on the
outside of the black stuff
so either way you got a problem and you
got to define the term so we know what
you're talking about
and then finally the thread is not the
ether it's not the nothing it's not the
black stuff
as you can see the thread the single
thread at least that we propose
underlies all matter
is an object it has beginning and an end
it's
uh it's a closed loop uh thread
okay so that's different than the ether
that you see on the left or on the
upper right there okay so no the thread
is not the same thing as the black stuff
and that's not synonymous with space
space is the black stuff
thread is the red stuff okay so let's
get uh
we need to define these terms so that we
can all talk
in a way that we comprehend you don't
like the definitions
no problem i have no problem with that
but then you have to do you can't say
bill you're wrong that's not the ether
which is what everybo every etherist
does he says
that's not the ether like this guy said
in quantum that says
that's not what quantum says that a
particle goes through all these
reaches well you could be mistaken but
then what is these right
don't tell me what ain't tell me what it
is well tell me both
if it ain't yeah it's fine you can say
bill you're wrong
you don't know what you're not what i
meant that's not what i mean then you
got to tell me what
that was the problem arises because
there's many different notions of the
ether and when you attack one
you attack ether a ether b says oh
that's not mine though
you know you attack either b either c
comes out and says oh that's not what i
meant
and you know and that's happened because
all these people come in and say what
the ether ain't everybody knows what it
ain't and it's whatever i say that
that's not it and i say it's a bunch of
particles okay fine i'm wrong
great i'll let me i'll concede tell me
what is
don't tell me what ain't it sounds like
the doll they always
define it but it isn't yeah and this
this is the problem the problem is
anyone who's
an etherist the thing you'll never see
them do is define the word ether
and again he better not be able to
define the word ether because if he does
it's a concept
not an object objects we point to
and if it's a bunch of particles it's a
concept because i say which one is the
ether which of those
white particles is the ether you say no
the whole thing is well that's myriology
a bunch of particles
is not a physical object any more than
table is a bunch of
particles in it or or an elephant is a
bunch of particles no an elephant's what
i pointed to
so when i point to the bunch of
particles moving there
you know what's the ether which one is
the ether you see the whole thing no no
that's not an object that's
that's what it's made of i need to see
does the whole ether move when you're
talking about light
you're saying the the ether vibrates and
that's light
well what the whole universe is
vibrating is that what you're saying
moving around as a whole
you know i can move an elephant as a
whole but i but to say that the ether is
one of the atoms inside the elephant
that's moving
up and down that's a different story
because that's not an elephant that's an
atom
and that's the same issue here if you're
going to talk about the ether you're
talking about the whole shebang
okay and then it's got to be made of a
single piece for the purposes of physics
you point and
name say that's the ether if you're
going to say that if there's all these
little particles
that are moving around then it that's
not a physical object that's a concept
that's muriology that's what the ether
is made of how can you bring up the
picture again which one
the one you just had well i had two of
them uh here's one uh
that one okay we got a question what's
the black stuff around
the thread it's uh space nothing
there you go it's nothing you're looking
at nothing
what's that stuff between the moon and
the earth that you see every night it's
called
nothing and you say well there's
something in there
uh between some things we have nothing
so make it as small as you want you know
on the moon there's 10 to the minus 11
torr
uh vacuum vacuum that means there's one
particle every so often
per volume everything what's the rest of
the volume i i want to know
someone to tell me what the rest of the
volume is it's called space that's what
gives
contrast to that little particle to that
atom that
that the the detector the ion gauge or
whatever
detected okay uh
moving on here two more issues
one file says
the same thing can be nothing and
something oh
depending on how you are looking at it
okay i'll look at it upside down i guess
something becomes nothing
okay the whole in the database
where this comment was inserted he's
talking about you know the uh
what happens inside a chip for example
uh that you have atoms in there
and the chip is in your computer and so
he's talking about this okay that's the
content he says the hole in the database
where this comment was inserted was
nothing in the context of memory
but the storage units the memory exists
on is something in the context of our
world
he's saying in other words when when you
store a bit
or a bite or whatever right let's talk
about a bit which is the smallest
unit of memory you could say
okay he's saying it when you store it
you know you you what are you storing
you're storing nothing but it becomes
something you know
that exists in memory
why does he get into this chasing his
tail thing
in this circular argument because he
doesn't define his terms that's where
the problem
starts that seems to always be the only
problem yeah
we have a language problem not a
question of uh
physics we have a first we gotta solve
the question of we got an english
problem yeah we have an english problem
alex
uh but is it a what is it
semantic problem first we define
so what is something we say that which
has shape well there's nothing that
which doesn't have shape now we can use
these words consistently why because
they are antonyms something is an
antonym
yeah so this is what we're proposing you
don't like this no problem
define something and nothing then we can
follow your training of thought
and here we have the word exist okay
again object plus location
something that has location okay so
that's our starting point so that we can
use these words consistently in a
dissertation in a talk and so this is
more or less what this file is referring
to i talked about that the other day
here you have the depletion region of
two semiconductor crystals you put them
together you create this
region where the extra electron from one
atom jumps over according to quantum
to the hole that is in the other
side of the in this case the p crystal
structure
increase this crisp this depletion
region okay so that's essentially how
semiconductors in this case a diode uh
are put together
you have a p-type uh usually boron uh
and m-type usually phosphorous when you
put them together okay
immediately as soon as they're touching
one with the other
you create this depletion region and the
theory is that the
extra electron of the n-type jumps over
to the hole
you know there's a missing electron in
the p
type crystal okay so that's essentially
an increases depletion region
which is very useful for diodes and
transistors
okay so that's the starting point okay
now let's get this other thing here
this is what i showed the other day
and what do we have here well what we
have here again is
holes absence of electrons okay
positive x absence of electrons
moving to the negative pole to the
cathode okay that's essentially
what we have and uh according to them
yeah yeah this is according to quantum
mechanics so the question here
is what object are we talking about
does that hole have shape well if you
take the rest of it away you know the
because the absence of an electron is is
not a physical object
that sounds like a you know like a word
wizardry we're saying that if
if you see the absence of a an electron
electron bead we're going to call that a
hole
and again that's like you know again
you're moving holes here
what are you moving you're it's like i
showed the other day
the game of the uh the puzzle you know
uh close to the camera yeah where if you
move this over
to here the the hole is moving in the
opposite direction so if
the little square here is the electron
the
hole the absence of an electron that's
what's moving in the opposite direction
and they call that are you going to call
that an object
does that have shape in the absence of
an electron
i mean what is a hole yeah you can't
really remove the rest of it and just
leave a hole
and much dangerous is to say that the
hole is positive
a positive i mean we could all more or
less try to figure out an electron being
negative is a hurricane like a
negative electron whatever negative
means but a positive nothing
i don't know i'm sure it's been asked
before but holes have shaped
are they yeah but as soon as you take
the ground away from
bugs bunny's hole there is what do you
have i mean what is a hole in space
which is what uh yeah what a black hole
is black hole is a hole
in space if space is nothing what is the
hole through what is a wormhole through
going to another universe
you drill through what so we have all
these problems
uh you have to define your terms of
something and nothing before we can talk
rationally and not chase our tails
around
that's the issue you got to get down to
language okay
that's where physics starts that's where
science starts at language
i guess whole isn't an object because
whole
is space is the absence of an object
well yeah no but that's not the issue
because if you have a hole you have a
circle
circular hole or let's let's say uh not
circular because that's two plugs
speaking 3d uh uh let's let's say let's
say cylinder shaped hole in the ground
right so we have a shape but that's not
an object because
the whole it's not it's not that it's
not made of atoms is that
it's just an extension of space it's an
extension of nothingness
which has no shape yeah there is no
shape because it's just an extension of
space
so weirdly enough a hole can have
shape in regular speech
but in physics it's not an object
because it doesn't actually have a shape
because the end of that hole
it's not it's not a it's not a 3d shape
right because
they've just said it is that the issue
in ordinary speech is that the word
whole
is a noun that's where the problem no
that's not what that's not the problem
but that is part of the problem because
you treat it as a subject of a sentence
you talk about
the whole no but that's not what i'm
saying i'm saying a hole has a shape
when we look at a hole we see oh okay a
cylinder
also but that's not the end of the
cylinder the cylinder keeps going off
into the rest of space which doesn't
have a boundary so it doesn't
actually have an end of shape one of the
arguments i make
in relation to that you know i work with
vacuum chambers
and let's assume perfect vacuum okay so
we have this chamber
cubic chamber one meter cube chamber
okay
you're gonna vacuum uh you're gonna
create a vacuum in that gym you're gonna
suck
all the air all the water all the atoms
from that chamber
nothing in there let's assume perfect
vacuum let's say we could achieve that
okay now you have your vacuum chamber
here on earth right
but the earth is moving around the the
universe
around the solar system for sure right
are you taking the hole with you are you
taking the hole with you
or are you are you creating new holes as
you move along
i guess that goes to the point the
merry-go-round
but i think that goes to the point when
you whenever you say there's always
space between two objects that's
essentially what you're talking about
because
yeah yeah yeah because because there's
there's there's always some
there's no such thing as an encapsulated
hole
right is that true or not there's no
such thing as that
i forgot to mention that earlier and
that's why i'm going to
close his mouth remember that between
any two atoms there's a rope
and that means that that means that
under the rope model
okay distance is the length
of a rope
[Laughter]
so uh we have to have a new definition
for distance or
a new notion we have to make sure like
we can have distance between two ropes
because there is no rope between uniting
or
or connecting two ropes but between two
atoms which is what we talk about when
we talk about existence and about
objects
we have a rope but remember the rope
continues to an atom which continues
to arrow which continues to an atom and
so on down the line so there is no
discrete object
so when we have two atoms it doesn't
matter what they belong to one belongs
to a chair the other one belongs to
a table we say well there's the distance
between the table and the
chair is i don't know three meters
and you say well what is between that
and because there's gravitational
attraction even though we can't
really measure it at that level but we
know that there's gravitational
attraction between the
chair and the table because of the
cavendish experiment
and the question is what's in between
there well under the rope model we have
a rope
and so the distance becomes the length
of the rope there is no empty space
so i just wanted to correct that there
to clarify that we're going we're on
deep
oh yeah a rabbit hole we got a lot of
questions right now so okay so
last question here see if we can get
this this is a
down the line of my son here who loves
this stuff
guy uh goes in there looks at ayn rand
which i covered in the past and he says
then what is philosophy then in the
alternative because i'm saying that
enran was not a philosopher
okay okay so what is uh philosophy the
alternative under the rope model and
very quickly here it is
okay here we have to define these terms
again so that we know what we're talking
about
and so here here's a summary and i'll go
quickly through this
we have science is divided into physics
and philosophy
physics deals with causes and mechanisms
and philosophy with reasons and purpose
and what is the purpose of physics uh
rational explanations of phenomena of
things that happened
and philosophy is the rational
explanation of behaviors
what is religion what's subjective it's
just opinions and beliefs
okay it's uh what you think is truth to
you essentially
it's uh personal and what are irrational
explanations that you see over on the
right
well that's when you start moving
concepts around and when you treat
concepts as physical objects that's the
primary one it's known as reification
and here is a definition of that so very
quickly so our definition
yeah this is our definition of the word
irrational uh these are the criteria for
irrationality and the main ones they're
refining concepts turning them into
physical objects
which is what this fell did with field
he turned it into
a physical logic he turned these numbers
into a rock
uh others is no definitions are using
them inconsistently
theory doesn't follow from the
hypothesis
okay uh we'll we'll open up the floor
now for questions if you're still around
okay so put these nice to each other
okay uh my son stole
my mouse from me now we got a long list
okay here we go okay let's go with it
[Applause]
farm out the questions any takes on
kantian philosophy
well uh kent again uh the issue i've got
with can't
primarily is with with respect to
physics
and i guess there's primarily two of the
two issues there one is
his notion of object was no different
than his predecessor
uh david hume okay and that's that they
could not distinguish
like anyone after them between what an
object is what it exists is
the other one i have uh with kent is his
notion of galaxy
okay he's essentially the guy who
probably is
one of the first persons to realize that
there's something called the galaxy
these island universes out there
and so he gets 100 points for that uh
again probably the first one i don't
know if he was the first one but i know
he talked about in his writings
and so i i credit him as the first one
unless someone corrects me okay
that's it that's all i've got to say
about can other than that he's not a
philosopher he's not a philosopher again
under my notion or my definition of
philosophy because philosophy is not
opinion recommendation
which is what kant did uh philosophy
is explanation of behavior which is what
kant
essentially did not do and nobody else
after
or beforehand from aristotle all the way
to ayn rand and
jean-paul sartre all these people did
the same thing they did
opinions and recommendations i don't
consider that philosophy
sometimes some of these questions are
asked in context of something that we're
speaking about in the moment and the
context kind of falls away when the
question is asked later
yeah so some of those i kind of have to
say all we can do is uh answer as best
as we can
and then uh someone comes later and say
bill but
you didn't answer my question or or i
didn't understand it or
you took it out of context okay fine uh
we need to clarify these things all i
can do is tell you
how i look at these things and the way i
look at them first we define philosophy
and philosophy is not what kant did
and i'm not talking about the current
one well i i'm just in general i'm just
saying
we have a different notion of philosophy
in this channel and because there is a
different notion you have to be careful
when you talk about
the word philosophy okay uh the next
question i think we already answered but
let's ask it again
what is the black in between when you
draw double row
single thread double uh double rope what
do you mean uh
double threads you mean probably uh a
rope double threads
keep in mind here's a rope okay here's a
rope and
why do we distinguish the blue from the
red
well hopefully there's something
separating the blue and the red the blue
and the red do not
merge and become one okay so there is
something
uh not a something but we see a contrast
between the blue and the red
and we call that contrast the one that
allows us to
visualize or see that contrast is space
itself
space is nothing except and space is
what separates
the table from the chair otherwise it
would be a single object and there would
be a single object in the universe if
there were no contrast to
each atom out there well i thought there
was only one object in the unit yeah
there is only one object essentially
but my point here is the only reason we
distinguish table from cherry is that
something gives
the table and chair contrast and
that something which is a nothing is
called space
so it's space that separates the two
threads okay
can you pronounce breakfast to crone yet
properly
guy gives me a hard time for about that
okay
i'm glad i'm not the only one there
christian
is that
uh black stuff are on the thread there
it is again um
still farming for questions here
on what basis can there be a nothing
what allows for something and nothing
it's not that something allows for that
that's again
that's like saying god created something
and nothing so we could
uh tell them apart it doesn't work that
way it's just
that's our universe that's what what's
out there we have
nothing which we call space or vacuum
and we have something which are the
atoms and um
ropes that interconnect them so we have
the somethings and the nothing
and uh some things are floating
or just moving with respect to other
somethings you know atoms with respect
to atoms
one side of the thread in the universe
with respect to another side
another portion of the thread in another
part of the universe or maybe locally so
so we
separate these on the basis of atoms we
say this atom is made out of threads
locally and this atom is made out of
threads
locally and we distinguish them because
there's this
space which gives them contrast
and that's the separation that we notice
there but otherwise
space is nothing there is no physical
object called space because
you define the word object as that which
has no shape and that's what space is
that which has no shape if there's
nothing between two objects
exactly they're one object right
well if if let's let's put it this way
if there was no such thing as space
to put it this way in those words
there's no other way to put this
okay if there is if god had not made
space so to speak we'd have a single
infinite block
of matter the only reason it's chopped
up
is that space forms the backdrop to this
thread that turns into somethings which
are the atoms
which are connected by ropes to other
atoms that's our universe that's how
simple
ultimately our universe is
can a hole be a square yeah i guess a
hole can be a triangle anything you want
can a hole be a square actually i don't
think so this whole implies 3d
uh well it depends i mean if you're
gonna talk i mean uh
we're talking about the real world or
the
we didn't even talk about imaginary
world and have a black uh
i don't triangle serve as a whole
in a paper okay for example okay
no matter what yeah it's going to be
you're right but i mean my point here is
that i don't think you can have a whole
square hole it depends on at that point
what you mean
if you define it as a three-dimensional
uh
enclosure within matter you know you say
well
this whole the cylinder this very
verbose i'll answer that one no
i can't understand how a mirror can
reflect the laser
in the rope hypothesis how do those
light ropes in the laser
ray get deflected in a perpendicular
angle
what do the ropes in the laser ray
connect to
other atoms remember remember and if i
i've got that in one of my real physics
uh
cartoons there every atom is
interconnected
so you have a rope connected from one
atom to the one
over here and now that one's connected
to the side as well
uh when we have reflection all you have
is is
the the um what is it
torsions moving along this rope
and then being uh rebounded
you could say or that atom pumps ropes
uh pumps the rope that goes to another
atom and so on down the line
so that's what a reflection is
reflection is simply
the relaying of that pumping
from one atom to this other atom that
atom back to
another atom that's behind you or maybe
your eyes or whatever
and then you have refraction which is
the continuing it's the rope that goes
behind that atom and takes that same
signal
by you know the atom is pumping back and
forth torquing the rope
and that signal now goes to an atom
behind
for example the mirror or the glass or
the wall whatever you've got in front of
you
so you know what is a shadow shadow is
that the wall stood in
between you and what's behind it
and the rope is still connected because
we have gravity
but that atom is connected to another
atom behind it and that's the shadow
because now now you don't have the same
pumping that you have from you
to the wall from the wall to that object
behind it you have shadow
umbra penumbra or whatever i think this
is exhibit a as to why language
or is it is no is not the language of
physics it's movies if you had a movie
you wouldn't need
all that time to explain that and i
think it would have gone a picture is
worth a thousand words a movie's worth a
billion words
you look at a movie and you see the rope
connected to an atom and an atom behind
it you see the movie
and you say okay i understand and here's
the torsion going from atom a to adam b
and from atom b to adam c which is
behind the wall you have shadow
what is shadow a lower frequency a
longer wavelength because
the atom is in a crystal lattice that
doesn't allow it to pump
at the same rate as the one coming in
but again if if you look at a movie of
that you say well oh is that what he was
talking about
that's like that's one of those
is worth a billion words you really have
to listen close when someone's speaking
in physics because
there's so many places you can get
tripped up yeah yeah if a planet is an
object how can there be separate objects
on a planet
well here's an object that's on this
planet it's a separate object
but imagine every atom that constitutes
this rope
is connected to every object in the
universe including to you
so we have separate objects because
what separates you from me are just
ropes and the ropes are intangible and
invisible
so we we see discreteness
or touch discreetness only because we
can't see or touch the mediators that
connect us
that transfer that are the mediators for
light and gravity primarily those two
see that's why i can't touch you i can't
touch i can touch you but i can't touch
the mediators
they're untouchable unseeable hopefully
it's like that because
otherwise we would be tangled in knots
mother nature was wise your son
definitely loves football which team he
supports munich
i actually don't watch football he's not
a soccer fan i am a sucker family he was
he's not i'm much dirtier than i look
no that's because of his haircut
what gives the hole its shape that which
gives the whole shape
is an object i guess that was
clarification not a question
yeah what software do you use for your
video streaming obs
what do you think about kant about what
we had though
oh yeah if motion
is two or more locations of an object
yeah
then an object that is spinning wouldn't
necessarily be in motion
yeah because uh when you talk about an
object
you're not talking about the top you're
talking about the
atom that constitutes the top
right no i thought i mean when object is
spinning yeah
it's not necessarily in motion but when
we talk when we use the word spinning
we mean it is turning in relationship to
other objects
but what's turning in with respect to
the other objects you're looking at one
atom at the surface essentially this is
what it comes down to
what you're looking at one atom at the
surface of the top otherwise you would
not know it's spinning
the the top could be a triangle there
that's just standing still as far as
you're concerned
and you say well it's spinning how do
you know that well because this atom
that was on this side
is now on this side okay and now that
atom moved with respect to something
else
including to another atom in the uh in
that top well we don't have to go to the
atom we can just talk about the top as a
as a singular how do you know it's
spinning that's what happens you have
other objects in the world that's what
we're talking about yeah yeah
if the top is in space if if you have a
single object
in space how do you know the top is
spinning even with respect to something
else that's
one of those unless you know that one
atom moved from here to
there with respect to something else
you're talking about one atom oh i see
what you mean
if if the top is made of one one how do
you know
if the top is is just standing still or
or spinning the only way you know that
is spinning i guess that's what the
question is no no but
i'm putting it in reverse because this
is the issue the issue is the only way
you can talk about spinning is when you
talk about
what atom but then kind of the top not
about the top
the top you don't know if there's a
single top in the universe
how do you know it's spinning well no
it's made out of a single piece it's
made out of a single piece
there's one top in the universe how is
how do you know it's spinning
well hold on if you have that's not the
question though it is
it gets down
you don't know if it's moving at all
because there's no other object but if
you have two objects in the universe
regardless of what they're shaped like
yeah you don't need to look at the atoms
that
yeah right yeah yeah you do you just
said it you just said it away
because you have one object here and one
object here and this one's doing this
we're done if there's a single
let's let's go let's go step by step
let's go step by step we have a single
object in the universe it's a top
top it has triangular shape right you
typically spin it by
twirling the top and at the top of the
top
little handler you twirl it and now it's
spinning right now we have a single
object in the universe and it's a top
it's made out of a single piece
there are no pieces no atoms it's just
made out of a single piece
how do you know it's spinning well wait
let me answer i i want to answer
i thought i was going to no no let me
answer first then you can answer
how do you know a spinny the only way
you know it's spinning if you talk about
two
you introduce the word two in there
either it's spinning with respect to
another object the whole
top is spinning with respect to another
object or
one side of the ad of the top is
spinning or
change its location with respect to an
atom
a component of the other side of the top
you're treating a little piece of the
of the top as it changed location with
respect to the first p
again you got two you no longer have one
it's like you're treating
it uh meteorology what you're saying is
the top is made out of atoms it's
spinning because this atom is no longer
on the on the left now it's on the right
and the one that was on the right is on
the left that's why you talk about
spinning
the only way you can talk about spin is
if you talk about two atoms
and in that case one atom is moving has
changed location with respect to the
first i think it's a loaded question
because
the question is how do you know it's
spinning that implies
i don't know in science we do not know
in science we define it's a loaded
question
no we define we define the word motion
and there's no
provision for observer that that
question doesn't really
it does because we just how do you know
that the top is spinning yeah we got it
over the
now no part we say in science we don't
know we don't use the word no because
that's observer and we don't have
observers in science what we have we
have to do
we have to define what we mean by motion
motion requires two
requires two whatevers and in this case
if the top is spinning and we're going
to say spinning is a verb meaning motion
the only way you can conceptualize it
when there's a single
uh top in the universe where it's made
out of a single piece
one atom has to move with respect to
another atom or one component or
whatever
you need to do you need the word tube
ever read hegel he's having to read
philosophy of nature but i'm sure he
gets something i have to
i read hegel primarily through marx
because i used to be a marxist a long
time ago and uh
marx introduced me to hegel and i had to
read hagel to understand marx because
hegel was marx's teacher
does the thread have shape in the
context of the universe
it makes up now again the only way the
thread has
any relevance is if you talk about
another unit a parallel
universe a multi-universe then you can
talk about existence speculate about
the possibility of another universe
that's not connected to ours you can say
the speed of light is different over
there than the speed of light here
you can speculate a lot of stuff that's
interesting
and again speculation only it's it's
nice to talk about these things
otherwise the thread has no context
whatsoever
especially when we talk about the word
exist in relation to the thread because
then you're not talking about the thread
you're talking about the word exist and
again i can make my thread exist
immediately by just putting another
thread
and then we solve the problem of
existence of the thread
an issue remains in space itself i.e the
basis of location
why will two objects not occupy the same
location
why will one object not be in two
locations zeno's paradox as well
well again when when we talk about the
thread
or the rope the rope and the thread can
go through each other i covered that the
other day to some degree
uh and i'm sure there's a lot of
questions on that because that's one of
the
tricky points that people are concerned
about as far as the rope hypothesis
so they can go through each other and
the question here is
does an atom go through another atom the
answer is no and you say well why is
that the case why can
why can the thread go through a thread
and here's the atom made of threads you
know we have the
the proton star is made of threads the
electron shell the membrane
is also made of threads and you say well
hold it you have threads and threads why
can they go
through each other here not over here
and again it's got to do with
what i say is agglomeration uh
how do we if you look at a table if you
could
have your telescope your microscope
god's telescope or god's microscope you
would see it's made out of gazillions of
atoms
you can't see one atom but you can see
the table
how is that you can see a table with
stuff that you cannot see
agglomeration or accumulation well
what's happening
you can see many atoms but you cannot
see one atom
and you you can see many ropes maybe
uh probably not but you can't see one
rope
okay many ropes yeah well again uh
yeah that's uh but you see the effect of
light not not the
mediator of light so that's the issue
yeah you see the the ropes yeah you
don't see the rope
you'll never see the rope because the
rope is unseeable you're talking about
something so
thin compared to an atom we can't see an
atom here you're talking something
so thinking with respect to an atom
you're you're not going to see the rope
and again the only way you can see the
rope essentially is
uh its effect in an atom which is the
the
little thump it gives when the torsion
arrives at the atom
and you take many of those and now you
can see the wall
otherwise you would not see the wall you
would not be able to see one rope
hitting one atom
on the wall you wouldn't if you if
that's the only thing that god made in
the universe
you would not be able to see that atom
in that rope the only way you can see
the wall
is by putting all these atoms together
and saying oh now that i have a
gazillions of atoms now i can see the
wall
or the table or whatever you're seeing
so yeah
and again all i'm saying is that atoms
collide against atoms because
now you have many threads that make up
the membrane
membrane suddenly brings the thread
into the touchable world into a world
that we can touch and see
if you just get one thread you can't see
it or touch it but if you have many
threads
it becomes an atom and when you have
many atoms now you can see and touch
you know the objects that mother in
other words what happens with the thread
it acquires
tangibility and see ability of
visibility
only through aggregation is it correct
to say that a thread by itself has a
fraction of tangibility
yeah i think there's some friction at
its level
but you're talking about something so
unimaginably thin
and it's got a property that we don't
have in our tangible world
which is i'm just going through objects
and you say well how come in our real
world we can't have tables going through
chairs
and you're telling me that the thread in
its world
in its uh plank length world maybe or
even smaller
how can a threat can go through another
well because in that world
uh it does function a little differently
first
and you might say well bill you just did
that to cheat so that you can get away
with murder
and no it's it's the real world that
mother nature has out there i mean
i can't pass my hand through this in our
real world
but obviously you know i can take two
laser pointers
you know i can take two laser pointers
and the light goes right through each
other
you know you can do this on your own
don't don't trust me you take a laser
you turn them on
okay and you shine the lights right
through each other and it's not like
when you take two shower
uh two showers you know
and run the water or two hoses and run
water through each other you'll see that
the water droplets go in every direction
that's not what happens to light there
is no sparks you know from the collision
of
photons and photons also and so you have
to explain you have to explain that you
got to say
hold it mother nature's world works a
little differently and quantum has
accepted that
where where light goes through light
photons go through photons
threads go through threads that's the
world you have to explain and if you're
going to explain that you have to make
an assumption you have to say well
there's a thread but the thread has the
ability to go through
each other and it only cannot go through
each other when it forms
when it's there's a whole bunch of them
forming uh electron membrane
now they've now they invented
tangibility
as we understand it in our macro world
i'm not sure what the context is on this
one but okay
basket house asked did he answer what
his criteria
he uses to show shape he still thinks
that object equals
has shape yeah this is the context okay
let's get the context on shape because
people say okay what did you mean by
shape
and they go on and on and on and on and
nobody asks
what did you mean by that or what did
you mean by which
uh what did you mean by has you know
that which has shape
why didn't you ask those questions and
people don't ask those questions because
it's like the key word is shape but it's
much harder to define the word has
the word that the word which than the
word shape
but that's not the issue here's the
issue the issue is that we need to
physics cannot be done without an object
we need to define the word object for
the purposes of physics
and the issue here is what criterion
or criteria are you going to use to
define the word object for the purposes
of physics that's the issue that's the
context that's what we have to
we've got the door locked we have this
conference here
and it's 8 billion people inside the
conference room we will not open the
doors we cannot leave until we define
the word object
the quest is what criterion what
criteria are we going to use to define
the word object are we going to say c
touch which is what mathematics uses
today they say anything you can see or
touch
are we going to use volume are we going
to use mass are we going to use
subject of a sentence exist what are we
going to use as a criterion
and we're saying that the criterion is
shape it's the universal property
the property that all objects have
there's no such
object that doesn't have shape and so
that's the criterion
and so when we talk about shape it's not
a question of playing
devil's advocate and say what did you
mean by shape no no
all we need to know is do you understand
the difference between shape and motion
do you understand the difference between
shape and mass do you understand the
difference between
shape and touch because we have to
choose a criterion
for the word object for the purposes of
physics
that's the context so we don't need to
badger the guy and say well what did you
mean by shape
you want to know what shape is very
simple just go to a
kindergarten and the kindergartners will
teach you what shape is and that
it goes like this you show them a cube
and you show them a ball
made out of the same material same color
same everything except what
and you say to the kids what's the
difference between
this and this and it's a shape
and you'll know what shape means and
that's what the criteria that we use we
use the
simple criterion known as shape i'm sure
you know the context of this because it
goes
over my head i have a question about
accelerated expansion the farther away
a galaxy is the faster it recedes from
us therefore
acceleration but the opposite the closer
this
the closer the slower expansion
why not deceleration in other words why
is the idea of a slowing acceleration
ruled out
uh i have a different take on that
completely different take
uh you probably some of you heard of
halton arp
and he was a guy who who was an
astronomer he had to leave the united
states he was hounded to extinction
almost
he died a couple years ago and he said
look the redshift
is not a measure of speed
away from you like a doppler effect this
is not a doppler effect
uh i i refer to it as tired light
i didn't hear yeah i didn't invent that
term this uh
term was already around and what it is
is this
redshift that these uh people are seeing
in the universe
are along the lines of what uh mr harp
mr art uh
explained okay and it goes something
like this
if you look at a rope you know take a
rope any rope
and tie it from one post to another like
take your grandmother's
uh clothesline if she's got a rope okay
it's got to be a rope a two stranded
rope one tied around each other
otherwise
do it yourself just tie a rope between
two posts
and you will know and tie it as tight as
you can
you know make it make it as taut as
possible
as you walk away from the post to the
center of the rope
you will see that the links are getting
longer
okay nothing change there's no motion
the the rope is just static there just
standing there and you will note that if
you were to measure maybe you won't see
it in a short rope but a long rope
if you measure the links you'll find out
that they get longer and longer
and that's what the this experiment uh
in the
harvard tower showed that when the guys
was in the
basement and he shot the light
to the top of the tower they said the
links are getting
the link well they said the the
frequency changes
and under the rope model very simple the
links are getting longer the farther
away you get the from the center of the
earth
very simple what's happening with the
galaxy same thing
when we're staring at a star you're
staring at a galaxy
it's not that the galaxy is receding
from us the farther it is away
it's that the farther it is away the
links get longer
and rather that's why the universe looks
red
to us everything's just so far away that
the except
distribution has to fall into the red
area
right and so it's not that galaxies are
receding
for some magical reasons away from the
earth as is the earth where the center
of the universe
it's that the farther a galaxy is from
us
the links get longer and that's called
the redshift that's one issue
the other issue you should keep in mind
is that the blue shifted galaxies
are the ones from the local group which
are 50 or 60 galaxies today that they
found
in the area and you take one like
andromeda galaxy and it's coming towards
us it's blue shifted
and so you say hold it how come all the
galaxies out there the ones that are
farther away are all redshifted
and this guy that's only barely 2.2
million uh light years away
is blue shifted it's coming towards us
why
and it's that this one might be coming
towards us momentarily because you know
these galaxies are going around each
other
they're moving it's like one comes
closer then goes farther away and
and so on down the line and so what
happens
what happens is that when you talk about
local galaxies some of them are blue
shifted because they could momentarily
be coming towards us
that is a blue shift a doppler that's a
doppler shift type
situation the ones that are very far
away that's totally
irrelevant to the doppler shift it's not
that it's coming or going it's that it's
so far away and the farther away it is
the redder it is
it's not that it's going away at a
faster speed away from
us it's that it because it's farther
away the links are longer and that's why
it's redshifted or more redshifted than
some of the closer ones
that's all it is questions since
we are the last generation of humans on
earth and
the money is no more why does bill write
and sell his books
because i'm crazy you want to collect
the magical disney dollars
no no the issue is that uh it's not so
much about selling or anything like that
it's that if you give it away from
for free nobody reads it that's the
issue and uh
i found out i found out that on and on
and on
i've given books away for free the
people and when i asked him well what
did you think of it oh i haven't read it
yet or
you can tell he hasn't read it because
he can't answer any questions one of my
friends has your book and he uses it as
a desktop razor i don't thought that for
a moment
a paperweight if there's only one object
in the universe the top
is not the universe the top
if the universe we're atop the universe
is a concept this is one
when we're talking about yeah and what
about it if there's if there's only one
object in the universe is that object
not the universe
well remember the universe includes
matter and space
universe is a concept and it's built of
two
and two is always concept okay two
objects but the space isn't an object so
we treat space we treat space as an
object
or again the definition of the word
concept is two words that
a word that includes two objects or two
words treated
as objects momentarily reify
space yeah in that case we treat space
as an object we say there's two objects
in front of us there's this black stuff
which we're going to call space and we
call this top which we're going to call
the object
okay so there's two objects that's what
space is two objects it includes two
words
object the object in this case the top
and space so
universe is the wrong word universe is
always a concept no matter what
and it includes space and the object
that's in there
that you pointed to in this case the top
so you can't say that
the universe moves are that the universe
is the top no the universe is the top
and space always is magnetism made of
atoms no no magnetism is made of threads
that's in other words a magnetic field
so-called field
that is a concept
is swept by threads
and again the way we explain like
attraction between two magnets
and i've got that illustrated again
that's oh in fact i have it here
let me get it because that's that's what
it is me
i can find it here uh where is it
the field of videos you can see around
here
[Music]
here it is found it
here it is picture's worth a thousand
words oh where they go
they're at the bottom when you push it
too far up it goes to the other side
okay there it is that's the magnetic
field what you're going to see there
threads
moving around if they move against each
other you have push
and when they're going in the same
direction
you have pull okay so if you stare at
that for two seconds you'll see
what the mechanism of a magnetic field
is
here you have north against north or
south against south and they're going to
push each other away because
one is going clockwise the other one
counterclockwise when you turn the
magnet around
okay now you see it's out against north
or north again south
and now they're going in the same
direction and one pulls on the other
that's the mechanism
the physical mechanism uh of attraction
and repulsion and what we're saying is
the magnetic field
is swept by in other words what's in
there in that invisible area are the
threads
that's the physical entity that's
producing this effect
uh let me pull it out
okay put it up here okay we're back
[Music]
why not define philosophy as rational
explanations of thinking
instead of behavior is that fine i can
also define it as that
uh no the answer is no and the reason is
we all think so we have eight billion
philosophers and then we would not be
able to distinguish between
aristotle and you because everybody's a
philosopher
now if we're going to use the word
philosophy in such a way like saying
oh i studied philosophy in college or
aristotle is a philosopher
we have to know what we mean by the word
philosopher we can't say he's just a
thinker
we're all thinkers you know so it's too
general to say thinker
or whatever you know i think that's it
for the questions
okay well then we'll see you again on
wednesday
and uh yeah if you put comments in
questions we'll try to answer them next
time around
we'll see you then